hey guys today i'm going to show you how
to boot your computer just a little bit
faster than it normally will
uh first thing you're going to do you're
going to want to go to your start menu
and type run if you're in windows xp and
select run and then type ms config
and run the microsoft configuration
system configuration utility
this utility under the general tab
i've chosen a selective startup i chose
the first two
and you can choose choose a diagnostic
setup start up at any time if you would
if you wanted to diagnose a problem
something uh but i suggest a selective
or a normal startup then under the boot
tab
uh we're loading windows vista and
that's the only partition i have a lot
of people will have a timeout of up to
30 seconds
this time out is not necessary make that
as low as you want just don't make it
zero
and apply
oh it says between three and 999 so
make that three don't make it anything
less
or anything higher than 999
um you can choose a safe boot and a new
gui boot will lo will load absolutely
blazingly fast but i actually like the
gui boot so i'm going to leave it but
that's the graphical boot where it does
the whole loading your desktop settings
thing and everything with the green bar
rolling across the screen so that's the
gui boot you can choose to disable that
and that'll just blew your computer
extremely fast next click the services
tab and disable anything you do not need
so i don't need that
um
certain things that you don't want to
boot with your computer and there are
tons of websites that will teach you
which
services not to
basically not to
uncheck
and but there are a few that i can
uncheck just here
looking at how many i have starting
i do have quite a bit starting uh i
don't need let's say i don't have a
tablet pc
i just saw where was it
um
i just saw a tablet pc input service i
can disable that because i don't have a
pc
so certain certain things like that will
help you
uh will help you to increase the speed
of your computer starting up when you're
done hit apply
and you might be prompted to re to
reboot after this but i haven't been
prompted yet also at startup disable as
many things as you do not need so go
ahead and
expand this so you can see exactly what
it is i have disabled quite a few
already down here
um
and these things you can always
re-enable at any time if you feel the
need
and then hit apply
tools i just leave that the way it is
and hit ok
this will hopefully increase the speed
of your computer starting up or decrease
the time it takes for your computer to
start up
and
maybe it'll
maybe it'll do your needs maybe it won't
but hopefully this will help you guys so
uh
otherwise um thanks for watching and
subscribe peace